(calm music)
(bright piano music)
(upbeat music)
- [Host] Have a quick conversation
about how you judge musical ability.
- Being able to adapt and improvise
is a big part of what is
inherently a musician.
Also playing multiple instruments
I think is a shirt tell sign
that you're talented
musically across the board.
- I would say there's like the skills
and then there's the sensibility
like how people are gonna
feel about your music
- Even like different genres
I feel like I would judge
it slightly differently.
Like if I'm at like a
Prague or a metal show
and I see some drummer,
someone just like going ham,
I'm like, hell yeah.
But if I'm at like a
Phoebe Bridgers concert
I'm just like, yes, queen break my heart.
Like won't like stra, you know
- Went through a breakup recently.
So I wrote a song last week
and I actually wrote it on the piano,
which I started playing last week so.
♪ The stars align so perfectly
when I first met you ♪
♪ Could have sworn that we
would get through anything ♪
♪ But the day light came and washed way ♪
♪ Any chance of sanity ♪
♪ I need to be free ♪
♪ Free me from us ♪
(all applauding)
Thank you.
(guitar strumming)
♪ Shut down and let me in ♪
(violin buzzing)
(calm piano music)
(loud drum beats)
♪ Ay, ay, ay, ay ♪
♪ I'm about to my ♪
♪ My mind, my mind ♪
♪ About to loose my ♪
♪ My mind, my mind, mh ♪
(calm piano music)
(slow-paced piano music)
(timer beeping)
- Okay, all right.
One second, one second.
- Don't worry we're not
gonna take personally.
- I know, I know, I'm sorry but I'm just.
I would say six.
I thought you were phenomenal.
You were absolutely brilliant.
This is just tough, 'cause
there's six of us here so like.
- That's totally fine.
- Five for you and I
thought like your piano
was also just so brilliant.
Like I thought, yeah, it was really crazy.
Four would be, I thought you
were sick your voice is great.
I would say three.
I thought you were phenomenal.
Your voice is beautiful.
I would say I'd give myself two,
but then I would give you number one,
just 'cause you, the yeah, the
drum's that's (beep) my mind.
So--
- Cool, thank you dude.
- Yeah, I thought he was a man.
I mean like I'm just a huge fan of drum.
Second, I saw that I was like lit
- And we have to make ourselves.
- [Host] Yeah you got that.
- Oh geez, okay.
I'm gonna have to give you a six
just because you know I didn't
see a lot of musical stuff.
Songwriting it'd be
probably a different number.
Five probably one instrument.
I didn't get a lot of variety.
Probably four,
I just saw a lot of drums.
- Yeah.
- I love the drums and you rip,
but I didn't get a chance I guess,
to see like what else you could do.
I'll give myself a three.
I'd probably give you a
two just for your voice.
I'm gonna have to give you a one
just because not only did you
basically nail that piece that you played
but like just the expression,
the dynamic was like huge.
- Dynamics, that was the word, so good.
- Yeah, definitely.
- I'm gonna give you the six.
I mean, I liked it.
I felt like she broke my heart too when--
- She probably broke it, she probably did.
- Okay, I'll give you the five.
I will give you the four.
So I would give myself the third.
Think I'm gonna ah, Jesus.
Ah, I think I'm gonna give you the two,
your piano especially as a pianist myself.
I think that's why I
vibe the most with her.
But just the piece that you
played, I was like, wow.
- Oh man, okay, yeah.
So I guess for sixth, just
the lack of experience I guess
but I love your songwriting.
- It seems to be a common thing.
- I think it was absolutely beautiful.
For five, I guess maybe Daniel,
four I would probably give it Sedo.
Yeah, I would give myself a three,
probably Michael a two
and then I'd say Mary, I'd give you a one.
I would listen to you like in
the car on a late night drive.
I got head chills when
you were singing so.
- Stop.
- I don't know if this is like a cop out.
I think I'm just gonna give myself the six
'cause then is that lame?
- Just rank yourself honestly.
- Oh (beep).
I'm really sorry, I think
I'm gonna give you the six.
The song was like super
moving and beautiful
and I would want to see it.
So I feel like that discredits you a lot.
- Did you cry?
- In the inside a little bit.
I think I'll give myself the five.
I think I'm gonna give you the four
and it might just be 'cause I'm in a band
and I'm like always seeing guitarists.
I think I'm gonna give you the three,
but (beep) you were so good,
but I'm also very like
pop and rock oriented
and then I think I'm
gonna give you second.
But in terms of like one of like,
I think what I would wanna
go see on a Friday night
I think it would be you
'cause beautiful voice and.
- Thank you.
- Solid guitar playing.
- Thank you so much.
- [Host] Do you feel like it's a betrayal
that voted the person
sixth who voted you first?
- I was literally thinking that.
I was like, no, this is like the worst.
I think we all have an
understanding that in a, yeah,
songwriting scenario is much different
than like come out here
and show your chops, so.
- I'm gonna have to give you the sixth
just based off of the fact
that I think if you practice more piano
and you know you get those
quote and quote 10,000 hours
because I think songwriting
and being able to accompany
yourself is extremely important.
I'm gonna give myself the five.
I would give you the four
'cause you went crazy
I, like there was like 20
different time signatures
that you were playing right now.
Like that was ridiculous.
I think I'm gonna give you the three.
I'm gonna give you the two
just because I almost
cried when you've played.
I'm gonna give you the one,
the fact that you can pick up
so many different instruments
and play it so well is something
that I strive as an artist.
Like I wanna be able to play
like 20 different instruments
that's all.
He not only played instruments
I have like literally never heard of.
I didn't know that that's the instrument
that's played in the background
of SpongeBob I had no idea.
Then he didn't even play all
the instruments he knows.
(upbeat music)
- Woo.
- Yeah.
(all applauding)
- [Host] Number six is Julius.
Number five is Summer.
Number four is Daniel.
Number three is Michael.
Number two is Mary.
Number one is Sedo.
(all applauding)
- Obviously, you know like
little disappointed I gotten last
'cause ain't fresh or last,
but it was, these people
are amazing musicians
and instrumentalists and everything.
You know, I thought I did
a good job I always do.
I think I do a really good job
of representing like my vulnerability.
Just being like as honest as possible.
I think I did my job.
I think, you know, I'm
proud of what I did.
- I was glad that I got
number one for the audience
but I feel like is very subjective
and in terms of the ranking
by musicians I got four
and I was also fine with it.
It's how they felt, you know?
And you cannot really
argue with that so I, yeah
- Music for me, isn't a competition.
It's an art form.
It's something that makes me
feel like I can express myself
and connect with other people
which is something that has always been
super important to me, so.
(calm music)